die einschläge können ganz plötzlich
kommen wenn die sirenen los gehen
bleiben nur sekunden um schutz zu suchen
das machen und josef prüfen noch einmal
ob sicherheitsweste und helm richtig
sitzen eine muslimin und ein jude die
mit vereinten kräften menschenleben
retten alltag inmitten der eskalation
ich möchte dich noch einmal daran
erinnern was wir tun wenn wir während
der fahrt einen alarm höhe
dann fahren wir rechts ran steigen aus
und legen uns auch die erde
wir nehmen die hände hinter dem kopf und
warten bis die raketen abgeschossen oder
eingeschlagen sind noch in der zentrale
gibt es den ersten alarm
die rettungssanitäter eilen in den
bunker hier in aschkelon so nah am
gazastreifen gab es schwere treffer in
den letzten tagen und die anspannung ist
auch den erfahrensten anzusehen
eben haben wir die entwarnung bekommen
wir können jetzt die daraus und schauen
was passiert ist assmann und josef haben
heute die nachtschicht
beide sind schon lange kollegen sie
müssen sich blind vertrauen nur in
notfällen richtig zu reagieren
dass josef jude und asma an eine stolze
muslimen ist macht für beide keinen
unterschied
ich fühle mich immer noch wie eine
normale rettungssanitäterin die
natürlich auch ein wenig bedrückt ist
und unter druck steht wie jeder wir im
moment aber ich sehe keine veränderungen
in der haltung gegenüber dass man mich
anders ansehen würde oder so das
verhältnis ist das gleiche ein warmes
hilfsbereites verhältnis da spielt die
politik keine rolle
von vertrauen auf das machen und josef
bauen ist ins der ort nur ein paar
kilometer weiter nicht mehr viel zu
spüren
seit tagen sind die straßen wie
ausgestorben
die jüdischen bewohner bleiben aus angst
zu hause oder packen silvia und jahren
ihre koffer um nach england an die
ägyptische grenze zu fahren möglichst
weit weg von den sirenen und den
ständigen panik wegen der situation
wir haben so viele kassam-raketen
abbekommen wir schlafen nicht gut wir
waren müde und erschöpft auf wir hoffen
einfach auf etwas besseres auf ein paar
gute tage und dann kommen wir wieder
seit 20 jahren lebt die familie an der
grenze zum gazastreifen
immer wieder wurden sie beschossen sie
alle nehmen tabletten gegen die angst
als silvia von dem tag erzählt an dem
die rakete in ihrem wohnzimmer gelandet
ist wird sie von ihren emotionen
überwältigt
so schwer sehr schwer
jaron kommen bitte mich kurz abkühlen
will mir fällt das zu schwer darüber zu
sprechen richtig schwer sehr schwer
wir haben zu viel in der familie erlebt
es geht nicht nur um mich sondern auch
um einen schwager seine tochter wurde
schwer verletzt meine schwester die
ganze familie eine rakete ist im haus
meiner mutter eingeschlagen mach du
bitte weiter was wurde gefragt wie du
dich in der situation fühlst wie ich
mich fühle
es ist richtig schwer darüber zu
sprechen
wir haben viel durchgemacht in dieser
stadt überhaupt der familie und die
verletzung meiner tochter
man fühlt sich wie schlachtvieh man weiß
nie wann das bei fällt in gaza auf der
anderen seite des zauns antwortet die
israelische armee am zehnten tag in
folge mit luftangriffen und artillerie
in fra struktur der hamas aber ganze
wohnviertel werden verwüstet
auch hier stopfen frauen und männer was
ihr in den trümmern ihrer häuser noch
finden können in plastiktüten um so
schnell wie möglich vor der gewalt zu
fliegen aber wo gibt es sicherheit wenn
bomben jederzeit und überall einschlagen
können
wissam ist mit seiner familie vor den
angriffen nach gaza stadt geflogen
in einer schule haben sie erst einmal
ein dach über dem kopf gefunden
1000 menschen auf drei stockwerken es
gibt kaum genügend platz für all die
familien die schutz suchen obwohl ich 40
jahre alt bin hätte ich mir so ein
bombardement nicht vorstellen können
stellen sie sich vor wie es drei jahre
alten kindern gehen muss wie sollen die
kinder so eine situation verarbeiten
ein paar alte fußball etwas platz auf
dem schulhof um sich zu bewegen
viel mehr ist wie es ihm nicht geblieben
um seinen kindern etwas abwechslung zu
bieten
als wir unsere sachen wollten habe ich
meine inlineskates mitgenommen weil das
mein lieblingsspielzeug ist die wollte
ich unbedingt mitnehmen
nachts im dunkeln sind sie barfuß durch
scherben zu einem verwandten gelaufen
der hat besser mit dessen frau den
kindern und der korona kranken mutter in
die schule gefahren
kein wasser zum duschen kaum
lebensmittel keine idee wie es
weitergehen soll
ich konnte bislang für unsere zukunft
nichts tun
nach 16 jahren der blockade haben wir
jetzt nicht einmal mehr eine sichere
unterkunft heute abend in jerusalem
jüdische und arabische frauen wollen ein
zeichen setzen gegen die spirale der
gewalt
vor den mauern der altstadt rufen sie
aus allen teilen des landes in weißen
gewändern zum frieden auf jetzt mit den
ganzen aufständen erleiden wir so viel
schmerz durch die wut die verzweiflung
die wir als mieter fühlen weil wir uns
auf unsere söhne und töchter sorgen sind
wir alle so ängstlich
ein stiller protest gegen den lärm des
krieges juden araber christen sie alle
hoffen dass die stimme der vernunft
weiter schallt als zorn und zerstörung
[Musik]